Maur there's plenty to love about
spider-man far from home no movie is
perfect for every great powerful moment
the film delivers that must also come a
responsibility to acknowledge whether
film came up short spoilers ahead while
homecoming introduced sir Walter's and
dais MJ far from home brings her and Tom
Hollands Peter Parker together
romantically and this is a delight the
two young actors are able to capture the
awkward budding romance between the two
high schoolers with natural chemistry
it's a sweet engaging relationship that
holds down the film spider-man battles
allusions responsibilities and his grief
over Tony Stark's death this version of
MJ is a bit more sarcastic than previous
Spiderman love interest in movies and
animated shows but the core of the
character shines through beautifully
meanwhile Holland is as great as ever
playing a Peter distinct from both Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield's
conceptions of the character while
remaining as recognizably spider-man as
ever
while the underlining subtext are far
from home is pretty clear about Peter
learning that with great power comes
great responsibility
the actual way the film connects
different parts of pizzas life is a lot
less focused Peter wants to rely on
Mysterio because Tony sucks death has
put a lot of pressure on him but why the
first film was about pizza learning to
be a friendly neighborhood spider-man
and turning down a spot with the
Avengers so the immediate turn around
and the very next solo sequel feels
weird even with fair - Peters desire for
a vacation is pretty relatable it's not
like he's letting a rubber run off for
money he's just pretty understandably
relieved that are seemingly magic using
superhero from another earth is willing
to take down elemental super demons
that's not exactly something that's in
Spidey's wheelhouse to begin with so the
idea that he's somehow failing to live
up to his potential rings false it's
been a long time coming but we finally
got to see classic Spidey Bella Mysterio
on the big screen the illusion is to use
his movie magic to trick and manipulate
spider-man has seemed like a perfect fit
for Spidey cinematic adventures
surprisingly though we've never gotten a
proper adaptation a planned spider-man 4
by Sam Raimi was once rumored to have
Bruce Campbell attached to play the ball
headed supervillain in a quick cameo but
far from home gives the character the
screen time that he's always deserved
even better Jake Gyllenhaal is
phenomenal it's a tricky supervillain
functioning as a sort of director and
Project Lead for a group of talented
ex-employees with a grudge against Tony
Stark anyone who saw Nightcrawler would
know that Gyllenhaal has a chops to play
a truly and
villain and his casting as Mysterio is a
delight it's a great performance as a
great villain considering how much of
homecoming is about pizza essentially
dealing with two opposing father figures
and Tony Stark and the vulture it makes
sense that has spent most of far from
home and mourning the loss of his heroic
mentor however the film goes beyond
Peter wanting to live up to Ironman
superheroism
by the time the credits rolled Peter
Parker's basically become iron lad first
he gets Bionic sunglasses that seemed to
basically be able to do anything related
to technology that he's given a ride
from Tony's old pal and sidekick in a
private plane where he designs his new
tat a logically advanced super suit even
the villains he's fought in the movies
to date all exist directly as a result
of Tony Stark's poor decisions it's a
pretty far cry from the dumpster-diving
boy from Queens the audience says
briefly saw in Captain America Civil War
Oh what do we have here retro tech huh
first story Salvation Army yeah Raj
you're a dumpster diver yeah I was
anyway look um and this a huge jump from
the constantly down-on-his-luck and rent
hungry Peter Parker of the comics and
previous films PETA wanting to live up
to the flawed ideal of Tony is a great
concept in theory still when most of his
own storyline revolves so completely
around iron man's it ships away as
spider-man as a viable character in his
own rise the sum Raimi spider-man films
undeniably a product of their times at
turns both deeply embarrassed about
superhero movies as a genre and deeply
committed to full-on weirdness there's
plenty to love and plenty to loathe
about the early 2000 superhero trilogy
however one aspect of the film thus in
questionably a success is JK Simmons
casting as belligerents newspaper editor
j jonah Jameson on the page cash money
for a picture of spider-man he doesn't
want to be famous and I'll make him
infamous thankfully far from homes mid
credit sequence feature Simmons
reprising his role as a spider-man
hating newsman he is hoping he gets an
even bigger role in the next one
homecoming at such incredible cameos and
performances Michael Keaton dazzled with
an incredible villain performance Marisa
Tomei made the most of a limited screen
time Chris Evans appearing as Captain
America in a series of taped PSAs was
delightful but Hannibal Buress says
laconic coach Wilson nearly stole the
show from everyone in only a couple of
scenes your gym teacher
we'll be conducting the Captain America
fitness challenge Thank You captain
pretty sure this guy's a war criminal
now but whatever I have to show these
videos is required by the state well it
doesn't necessarily make a whole lot of
sense for a gym teacher to go on a class
trip to Europe instead Martin Starr
reprises his role as mr. Harrington and
j.b smoove joins as a new teacher mr.
Dell it's hard not to feel like we were
robbed of seeing Barris and far from
home all we can do is hope that he
returns for the sequel check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]